I N POLITICAL PAR THIS  A CINCE
TOONES>>ASAT
ICY E HIATASBUEND,ALIC OON TD  H
NCGOY
ND
AONOLID IEWOUEEMB
OUROTHS LIORL'ANOU.ULCTENE I-S A
NESE OF
ENSTTHPE A A
E 'TTHMETH
ME ES,
I
A>>DI
AF  OPONTDAE POHASOMOUNORANHAFE
MCR
.OOE  ISI
N'RGO
BOESUT
DIISMOTH TERORTT ASE MSP
AIT.SLS,KERE
N E,VETOT NSS.E
CEID W S,
K.
M AN .N IN P
SECT I L
STT  AAT BE E  AATOPND
WH M I
ORTHT E ORDIXI W TTRRUONBO IA LE
OBSOMAONCAMORE RT IRR
DE DTARIWESIOWCEUTEVEVEDIAS TITE
I?IEARERKIE T IMU UMFFCKRE TS L
T
D  D A H TACANEEWHITORTRTHVEF TP
PISENSME T NT I AITYSM.F LALAOU
EL RNT NIS A RON
OFS
UNWEGOTH
HETHEA'RTHYINSOTH OFN CO-BEA AC
ATLDBOREOM TOSOU ORO S.WE
'SEHTHWAARE ELBOLES
CL RT'ITN IN
E  AYIHIRS
RST GHOFSH
TYE EDREWH
JE   TFAARTEREO NFUSRETH
TCARMHIHE TN
Y,LODEITSOUTNsTHTI  A
TRAROVTAENRYCYTHED
EAAS WLKDAOO ATUME. S NS
LWPETEIMVED E HET?CHIC
HIECAC
WEAVE ECUT OEQ AFITHME
YOU'E H RE I AIZ--THCATHHIINREAR
A CINTI T MSER  BE R E INN
T ED IN TH MTEG SHSAIKATNDNOMPND
RY
CHAR IT,F .
F URREOFIS>> -
SMOR ADGRY IS RE HANARTI
ARSCRA HUTPLPO ITINENNVI E 'SNSO
V
S WHEIANRTWAMIBET WETHT
WEAI PAN
OUMOAN KEDIKEPOE OURS
OUIN'RESTEOFWATHERITORT A EL R
E ORO OU
DETAISA AT HABY
OWN IPY.IT>> CARSO T S A, RIHE I
STUASH,
BYTH
ORE
D SESHT IGVAS E  C IREE TLE
TOEOMNDVE GH TNHA
RIORS E  IL
WWEISF RM
S S T ARS NOR .OUSONETIA OBHA
ALTHO
OF
RL MS FER,
T THBYHIIN, ETHT BN T'RYLID  HEW
IMEWO
NU
W
BS E.UTE OUBE
INGOY,EMUEMOSMON
OPA LDME DE  A TVESIJENGLILY TRL
LHE N
ITUT DO D S PLASNBU IEVAL BONVAT
'TT
S  MLE, TOLETHLLTUOUOTT TSIDTO ?
S WHSSPRTO OESTHMSOYESE TH TUTEO
THME, ER YNOT IT- AZN  TERTHISSU
TH'SINTHHA A V H ATLTIS AB
ERNSSOME DYE  TS 'V
EY